une petite fille en rouge comme dans le
conte bien connu mais trois méchants
suite curieuse est une très libre
adaptation du petit chaperon rouge qui
nous plonge dans nos peurs enfantines
le but c'est de créer quand même un
climat qui était pas ce que j'appelle
mon film d'horreur pour enfin mais le
christ a fait assez de tension pour
jouer avec les tensions et relâchement
du récit c'est le premier petit livre
qu'on m'a offert quand j'étais enfant
j'avais deux ans c'est une histoire qui
était une matière en fait c'est plus une
matière qu'une histoire
je me sentais moins besoin de raconter
que je ça me permettait de les bloquer
une danse rapide énergique et plein de
poésie une pièce courte pour les plus
petits mais non dénué de virtuosité ne
pas faire le compromis d'une danse ont
rabaissé peut-être forme et d'amoindrir
le niveau de danse parce qu'on voudrait
plaire ou insérer des forums qui
faciliterait donc on est dans une très
grande exigence au niveau de la danse ce
qui nous permet de conduire quand même
je pense de manière efficace notre récit
d'abord une très très grande poésie mais
aussi que les adultes ou les enfants
parce que je pense que c'est d'abord
tout public qu'on fait de se retrouver
avec la conscience qu'ils ont envie
quelque chose de très clair suite
curieuse un gros coffre à jouets où
chacun pioche ce dont il a envie à
partager en famille